it's the penultimate day of voting in
these referendums they've been widely
disregarded not just here in Ukraine but
Across the Western world as a sham vote
there's no sense that the votes are
taking place in free conditions with
people able to vote as they wish they're
taking place in four regions in Ukraine
two of them in the donbath the luhansk
and Donetsk Regions they're already
recognized by Russia alone as being
independent republics and then the other
two regions zaparizia and her son in the
South the vote there is about for
Independence and then accession into
Russia whether the people there want
that as I've said nobody regards the
results that are due out tomorrow as
legitimate there's also no doubting what
the results will be clearly and this is
a a referendum in name alone and the
results will be for those four regions
to end up ultimately being absorbed into
Russia and that is something that for
here in Ukraine is an absolute Red Line
president zielinski has repeatedly
warned Russia not to take that step to
Annex more of his territory he has made
it very clear that the ukrainians will
not fight will not stop fighting until
they have reclaimed all of that
territory so what it does change though
is the status of the land that will then
be fought over because from the moment
that Russia recognizes as expected those
territories as being Russian rather than
Ukrainian the response that it has
warned it could unleash then escalates
all the way up to potentially a nuclear
strike and the nuclear threat is what
western Nations including the United
States are incredibly alive too we
understand that there have been
conversations in public and in private
um between the Western allies and Russia
warning of catastrophic consequences in
the words of the United States that
would happen should Russia decide to use
the nuclear option it's an incredibly
dangerous moment and it's all really
been accelerated because of Ukraine's
successes on the battlefield with its
counter-offensive reclaiming sways of
territory across the northeast of the
country also pressuring Russian
positions in the South so Russia is
escalating itself in turn and so the
next few days weeks will be incredibly
important and potentially decisive